HORRIFIED.
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU, TRACE.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT VIOLENCE,
PHYSICAL ATTACKS AND THREATS IN
OUR POLITICAL SYSTEM WOULD SHOCK
ALL OF US, BUT THIS POINT
UNFORTUNATELY, NOBODY IS REALLY
SURPRISED.
IT ALMOST SEEMS NORMAL.
JUST LAST YEAR PROGRESSIVE
ACTIVIST TRY TO MURDER AN ENTIRE
FIELD OF REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS
PRACTICING BASEBALL.
HE GRAVELY WOUNDED ONE OF THEM.
STRANGELY YOU DIDN'T HEAR CALLS
FOR GUN CONTROL IN THE DAYS
AFTER THAT HAPPENED.
IN THIS POINT WE FORGOTTEN THAT
HAPPENED AT ALL.
SO THE CYCLE HAS ACCELERATED.
USING FORCE AGAINST REPUBLICAN
OFFICEHOLDERS AND CONSERVATIVES
NOW SEEMS LIKE A FEATURE OF OUR
POLITICAL LANDSCAPE.
>> SHAME!
SHAME!
>> NO BORDERS, NO LOSS!
SANCTUARY FOR ALL!
IF KIDS DON'T EAT IN PEACE, YOU
DON'T EAT IN PEACE!
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THIS REALLY
ABOUT?
SUDDENLY THIS KIND OF RAGE IS
EVERYWHERE.
YOU'VE SEEN TAPE LIKE THAT FOR
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS, BUT WHO
EXACTLY IS IT AIMED AT?
WHAT IS THE POINT?
WELL, REPUBLICANS, OBVIOUSLY,
ARE THE FOCUS OF IT.
IT CONSERVATIVES MORE GENERALLY.
ANYONE ELSE WHO DESCENDS FROM
ONE TRUE FAITH OF CULTURAL
LEFTISM.
BUT REALLY THE TARGET IS THE
COUNTRY ITSELF.
THE LEFT IS ANGRY AT AMERICA.
THEY SAY SO ALL THE TIME.
THIS IS NOT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
YOU GREW UP IN OR THAT YOU
REMEMBER IF YOU ARE OVER 30.
THAT PARTY MAY HAVE STOOD FOR
SOME BAD IDEAS, AND IT DID, BUT
THERE WAS NEVER REALLY A
QUESTION ABOUT ITS FUNDAMENTAL
LOYALTY TO AMERICA, OR THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE.
THE PARTY OF FDR AND LBJ, EVEN
OF BILL CLINTON, WAS BASICALLY A
PATRIOTIC PARTY.
IT WAS AN AMERICAN PARTY.
NOT ANYMORE.
IN 2018, ANYONE WHO CONSIDERS
AMERICA A DISTINCT PHYSICAL
PLACE WITH MEANINGFUL BORDERS
AND ITS OWN HISTORY AND
TRADITIONS AND LANGUAGE AND
CULTURE AND VALUES, WON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, INDEED MAY NOT EVEN BE
ALLOWED IN THAT PARTY.
TO MODERN DEMOCRATS, THE LEADERS
OF THE PARTY, AMERICA IS AN
ECONOMY WITH LAND ATTACHED.
IT'S A MASSIVE PRIVATE EQUITY
SCHEME FROM WHICH THEY ARE
BENEFITING.
IT'S PEOPLE ARE INTERCHANGEABLE
HUMAN WIDGETS TO BE DISCARDED
AND PLACED WHEN THEIR USEFULNESS
EXPIRES.
WASN'T ALWAYS THIS WAY?
WASN'T ALWAYS WHAT AMERICA WAS
LIKE, YOU MIGHT ASK?
SHUT UP, THEY WILL EXPLAIN.
BEFORE OBAMA GOT ELECTED,
AMERICA WAS TRULY A HORRIBLE
PLACE, A NIGHTMARE.
WATCH NEW YORK GOVERNOR ANDREW
CUOMO EXPLAINED.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
IT WAS NEVER THAT GREAT.
>> Tucker: IT WAS NEVER THAT
GREAT, SAYS THE GUY WHO
INHERITED HIS JOB FROM HIS DAD.
HIS REMARKS GOT SOME COVERAGE ON
THIS CHANNEL, BUT THEY WERE
HARDLY UNUSUAL FOR CUOMO'S
PARTY.
BEFORE SHE FOUNDED THE #MeToo
MOVEMENT, SENATOR ELIZABETH
WARREN SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TELLING AUDIENCES WHAT AN AWFUL
COUNTRY THIS IS.
HERE'S ONE EXAMPLE.
>> THE HARD TRUTH ABOUT OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM, IT'S
RACIST.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I MEAN FRONT TO BACK.
>> Tucker: RACIST, FRONT TO
BACK.
IN OTHER WORDS, OUR LAWS AND OUR
POLICE ARE ILLEGITIMATE AND THEY
ARE IMMORAL.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT VIOLATING OR
IGNORING THEM.
TEXAS SENATE CANDIDATE ROBERT
O'ROURKE RECENTLY TOLD A CROWD
THAT POLICE IN AMERICA MURDER
AND IMPRISON PEOPLE SOLELY
BECAUSE OF THEIR SKIN COLOR.
THAT'S FACTUALLY UNTRUE.
IT'S RIDICULOUS, AND OF COURSE,
HE DIDN'T EVEN TRY TO PROVE IT
WAS TRUE, BUT IT'S ALSO A SLUR
ON DECENT PEOPLE OF ALL COLORS
FOR TRYING THEIR BEST TO SERVE
THIS COUNTRY AND LAW ENFORCEMEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE SAID
SOMETHING, BUT THEY DIDN'T, THEY
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO, NOBODY IS.
DEFEND AMERICA AND YOU WILL BE
PUNISHED.
FORMER CONGRESSWOMAN MARY BONO
LOST HER JOB THIS WEEK AS
PRESIDENT OF USA GYMNASTICS.
WHAT DID SHE DO WRONG?
SHE LEVELED A VEILED CRITICISM
AT COLIN KAEPERNICK.
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE NO.
COLIN KAEPERNICK MAKES MILLIONS
DENIGRATING OUR NATIONAL
SYMBOLS.
HE'S A HERO, NIKE HIRED HIM.